this is part of my collection do you
know what this is no I have no idea so
this is something you have seen before
oh my God so that's a replica it's not a
replica it's not a replica this is the
actual prop this is yours from the third
film okay now this is pretty cool I mean
I haven't seen this thing in years oh
it's heavy isn't it and there's a really
interesting story with it this it was
actually the same prop was used by Alec
Guinness in the first movie as his
special effects lightsaber so if you see
how the emitter actually spins and there
was a motor in the handle here and as I
understand it the blades were coated
with a reflective material yeah it was
movie screen material right because that
reflects the Life Source back at
hundreds of times the intensity yes yeah
you know and you had to wire up your
sleeve and a battery pack on your belt
so you you'd go like this and freeze
they'd run in and put that pole that
you're talking about on it and then run
out just like they did the effects on I
Dream of Jeannie or whatever right I
think it pop pops in